[Musique]
ouais
alors vous vous demandez certainement
comment j'ai fait pour filmer cet ours
polaires de cyprès
et bien il se trouve que je suis
récemment allé jouer à l'explorateur sur
la banquise du groenland
alors j'imagine déjà ce que vous vous
dites encore un aventurier qui vient
nous bassiner avec le réchauffement
climatique
vous avez déjà entendu cette histoire
des dizaines de fois et vous aimeriez
entendre quelque chose de différent
quelque chose de nouveau
eh bien oui encore un aventurier vous
avez raison je serai ce soir votre
petite touche de verdure la piqûre de
rappel pour vous administrez une
nouvelle dose de réactifs face à
l'urgence climatique
car depuis peu on m'a collé l'étiquette
de navigateurs au service de
l'environnement alors je joue le
capitaine planète dans les écoles et le
mike horn locales dans ma ville
je vaccine à tour de bras contre
l'inaction climatique en proposant des
déclics de la motivation et de
l'inspiration autour de moi
alors pour celles et ceux qui seront
sceptique face à ma stratégie vaccinale
ne vous inquiétez pas c'est très rapide
et indolore
mon idée est simple je pars du principe
que nous avons tous déjà reçu un certain
nombre de doses et qu'il n'y a quasiment
plus de climato sceptiques en france
personne ici n'ignore le réchauffement
climatique et son fonctionnement
je pars aussi du principe que nous
connaissons déjà des solutions pour le
combattre et que nous sommes capables de
les utiliser
que si les choses n'évoluent pas à notre
avantage et celui de la planète c'est
simplement parce que nous n'en avons pas
envie
pour des raisons que l'on ignore et qui
sont certainement propre à notre société
moderne force est de constater que nous
sommes globalement amorphes et inactif
face au cataclysme qui a débuté un peu
partout sur terre
ma stratégie mon rôle consisterait donc
à susciter cette envie d'agir de manière
la plus efficace possible
mais comment faire ça comment susciter
une envie un sentiment une envie une
émotion à contre courant de ce que nous
impose cette société moderne
et bien mon rôle pourrait peut-être
tenir en une phrase créer du lien entre
les gens aient un endroit du monde en
grande détresse climatique
7 droit se serait l'arctique et sa
banquise cette région m'intéresse car
elle est touchée trois à quatre fois
plus vite par le réchauffement
climatique
chaque année ses paysages ses
populations humaines et animales sont
bouleversés par des cataclysmes
environnementaux
les scientifiques estiment qu'à ce
rythme la banquise disparaîtra
totalement de manière périodique dans 15
ans en 2035
l'autre intérêt de cette région et son
capital sympathie grâce aux ours
polaires aux icebergs et aux inuits mais
aussi grâce à la reine des neiges et au
père noël elles inspirent généralement
amour émerveillement ces symboles que
l'on appelle aussitôt thèmes seront ce
que je pourrais utiliser pour créer du
lien entre l'arctique et les gens que je
toucherai
ces personnes seraient celles de mon
entourage géographiquement proches car
plutôt que de chercher à toucher le plus
de monde possible l'idée est ici de
chercher à cibler les personnes à portée
d'une interaction forte et qualitatif
car j'ai grandi à rennes et que je
connais cette ville par coeur mon action
serait beaucoup plus impactante si elle
s'adressait à vent tourner
ceci étant dit nous sommes encore plus
de 450 milles à habiter l'agglomération
ce qui fait beaucoup de monde a touché
d'un coup
j'ai donc choisi de cibler les enfants
en classe de cm1 et cm2
alors je n'ai pas pensé à eux comme
étant les futurs sauveur de notre
planète dont il est déjà trop tard je
pense en 2035 en la banquise commencera
sa disparition il aura alors 25 ans et
seront encore bien loin de pouvoir peser
sur le monde
non j'ai pensé à eux car ce sont je
pense de fabuleux messager pour diffuser
des sentiments des émotions de
l'empathie grâce à eux je suis certain
que la banquise et sa protection
entreront dans de nombreux foyers de la
ville
cette stratégie qui visait donc à créer
du lien entre les jeunes rennais et la
banquise s'est traduite par un projet
d'expédition
un programme d'éducation à
l'environnement nourri par une aventure
à destination du grand nord
l'idée était de faire un aller retour
jusque dans l'est du groenland
afin de jouer le reporter spécial sur
place et en direct pour les enfants
pendant trois mois une aventure de trois
mois qui a eu lieu cet été et pendant
laquelle voilà j'ai fait le trajet de
rennes jusqu'à saint-malo en vélo puis
de saint malo oren landes en voilier sur
place j'étais seul à bord d'une toute
petite embarcation que j'avais emmené
avec moi
elle me servait de cellule de survie de
moyens de transport et de studio de
communication
pendant un mois j'ai enchaîné les
visioconférences avec plus de 30 et
classe classe de la ville
répondant aux questions sans filtre des
enfants que j'avais déjà rencontré
pendant l'année
et à chaque fois je me rendais compte de
la puissance de l'événement pour eux
il venait de discuter avec leurs amis
aventuriers en direct de la banquise en
pleine disparition
c'était un truc de dingue
au 1er août ma mission était terminée
j'étais de retour à rennes et on me
fixait déjà un nouvel objectif celui de
susciter cette même envie d'agir auprès
de 3000 spectateurs d'un thé leaks
alors du coup je ressors ma bonne
vieille stratégie et l'idée de créer du
lien entre vous le public et la banquise
avec mon meilleur totem l'ours polaire
celui là même que vous avez croisé au
tout début de mon me demandent
l'intervention
cet ours polaires et tout son écosystème
risque de disparaître d'ici quelques
dizaines d'années
et même s'il a voulu me manger les deux
jambes mon souhait certainement le vôtre
est de préserver son écosystème vital
pour notre terre
ceux ci ne fasse ce ne sont pas que des
mots c'est bien réel
et mon rôle car je suis votre voisin
votre ami votre collègue que j'ai
certainement rencontrer vos enfants à
l'école ou que je vous ai croisé dans la
rue est de vous fournir une preuve bien
réels de ceux là la banquise et les ours
polaires risque de disparaître si nous
ne faisons rien et nous devons
réellement intégré cette information
pour construire notre futur
ça va je pas trop
c'est ça le mauvais côté de ce rôle je
passe le montant a répété des évidences
que l'on a un peu marre d'entendre
j'aimerais que nous prenions ensemble un
dernier instant pour réellement intégrer
des images que je vais vous montrer
elles ont été tournées dans l'est du
groenland cet été alors qu'une vague de
chaleur particulièrement inhabituel la
toucher regardez bien car tout ceci est
bien réel et tout ceci risque de
disparaître
merci
[Applaudissements]